MARK JAGO: We're going to talk
about four paradoxes that
touch on the topic
of infinity.
First one, we've got
the Hilbert Hotel.
This is a hotel with infinitely
many rooms.
And at the moment, there's
somebody in every single room.
So it's a full hotel, and then a
new customer rolls up at the
reception desk.
Now, you might think they're
going to turn him away because
the hotel's full.
But the manager's clever.
And here's what he does.
He shifts the person in room 1
to room 2, and the person in
room 2 to room 3, and the
person in room 3 to
room 4, and so on.
Everyone gets shifted
forward one room.
And because there's infinitely
many rooms, you never run out
of rooms to put people in.
And when you've done all
of this, room 1's free.
So the new guest gets put
in room number 1.
So you can fit in a new guest.
You can fit in two new guests.
You could fit in
10 new guests.
And even if an infinite bus of
new customers rolls up, you
can fit them all in.
I guess it's that when I first
heard the description, I
thought, well, that
hotel's full.
You can't fit anybody in it.
That's how full hotels work.
But then once you're shown that
you can fit as many new
people in the hotel as you like,
you learn something new
about infinity.
So your intuitions change.
And the trick is because it's an
infinite hotel, there is no
final room.
If there were a final room, you
could count all the rooms,
and there wouldn't be infinitely
many of them.
I think he's using the idea to
say, infinity is interesting,
it's philosophically interesting
because you might
have thought things
went like this.
But they don't, and we can show
mathematically that they don't.
Paradox number two--
this is the paradox
of Gabriel's trumpet.
So the idea is we have this
mathematical shape, this
mathematical object.
And it's shaped like
a trumpet.
It'll start off here, and it'll
taper and get thinner
and thinner and thinner and
thinner and thinner.
And it tends off to infinity,
getting thinner and thinner
all the way.
So that mathematical object has
an infinite surface area.
But the volume it encloses, the
air in the center of the
trumpet, is only a
finite volume.
Suppose you were told
you had to paint the
inside of that trumpet.
Well, on the one hand, you've
got to paint an
infinitely big surface.
So you're going to need an
infinite bucket of paint.
But on the other hand, you could
just take a finite, big
enough can of paint, tip it into
the trumpet, and let it
filter its way down.
So it looks like you only need
a finite amount of paint to
paint an infinite
surface area.
That's really, really strange.
If we're thinking about real
physical paint, you just can't
paint the whole surface.
Because it gets so thin at one
end that you're just not going
to fit the paint down there.
So I guess the clash arises
when we think about the
difference between the
mathematical idea of a surface
and the physical idea
of paint, which
is real thick stuff.
If we had mathematical paint
where the molecules had no
size whatsoever, looks like
you'd need an infinite amount
of that to cover that infinite
surface area.
He thought there was something
really strange going on here.
He gave lots of proofs of this
idea because I think at first,
he thought he'd made
a mistake.
And lots of mathematicians
thought that there was
something wrong with the idea
of infinity, that maybe
somehow we should
banish infinity.
Because puzzles like
this clash.
They show there's something
wrong with the idea, so we
should somehow ban it from
our mathematics.
But in fact, infinity works
just fine in mathematics.
But we have to sometimes change
our ideas about how the
world works to fit it in.
Number three-- so this is the
puzzle of the dartboard.
So we suppose we've
got a dartboard,
and we've got a dart.
And we're going to throw the
dart at the dartboard.
And let's just suppose we're
guaranteed 100% chance to hit
the dartboard.
And then we ask the question,
think about the exact center
point of the dart.
And we think about an exact
point, a mathematical point on
the dartboard.
And we ask the question, what's
the chance our dart is
going to hit that exact point?
And it turns out we can't
give a sensible answer.
So suppose on the one hand that
we say, it's got a chance
greater than 0 of hitting
that point.
Well, there's a problem
with that.
If it's got a greater than 0
chance of hitting that point,
the same goes for every other
point on the dartboard.
And there's infinitely
many of them.
In fact, there's a big
infinity of those
mathematical points.
When we add all those chances
together to give us the chance
that the dart's going to hit the
dartboard at all, we end
up with an infinite
probability.
But we can't have an infinite
You can't get a probability
bigger than 1 that something
will happen.
OK, so we've got a problem with
the idea that the chance
of the dart hitting that
point is bigger than 0.
So on the other hand, what
happened to the chance of 0?
Well, that's also strange.
Because if the chance of hitting
that point is 0, we
could say the same
for every point.
So the chance of hitting any
point on the dart board is 0.
It's not going to happen.
But that's really strange
because we're sure the dart's
going to hit the dartboard
somewhere.
Again, one thing philosophers
say about this is the idea of
banning infinity.
So we say, don't think about the
exact mathematical point
of the dart.
We think about an area--
any real physical dart has
an area at its center.
And we think about what's the
chance that it hits an area on
the dartboard.
And then we divide these
up in a finite way.
And the problem goes away.
As the area gets bigger, the
probability that the dart hits
there is bigger.
As it gets smaller, the
probability the dart hits
there gets smaller.
BRADY HARAN: So it's this kind
of granular nature of our
existence that gets
us out of trouble?
MARK JAGO: Yeah, that's right.
So if everything that we think
about is an area rather than
an exact point, the
problem goes away.
But that's not completely
satisfying.
After all, we can think of an
area getting smaller and
smaller and smaller and
tending to infinity.
Shouldn't we have a decent
answer to this problem when we
get to the infinite case?
And maybe we don't have a
very good answer to it.
OK, so here's the
fourth paradox.
This is perhaps the most
interesting one of them all
because it relates to what
rational humans should do in
betting games.
You go to a casino, and they
put a pound in the pot.
And they say, we're going
to flip a fair coin.
And when it lands on a tail, you
get whatever's in the pot.
If we flip a head, the casino
doubles what's in the pot, and
we play again.
If it gets a tail, you get
what's in the pot.
If it's a head, they
double the pot,
and we carry on playing.
But then they ask you the
question, how much would you
pay to get into this game?
Name your price.
You've got to pay something
to play.
What would you pay?
And I think most people think
about this a bit and say
something like, maybe
a few pounds?
Maybe if you're rich,
you'd say 20 pounds.
The mathematical theory, on the
other hand, tells you, bet
whatever you've got.
Stake any amount of money you
can get your hands on on this
game, because the expected
winnings is infinite.
Your expected take home is
infinite if you play the game.
So the way we work out the
expected take-home winnings is
we look at each case.
If you flip a tail on
the first go, how
much would you win?
Add it to if you flip a tail
on the second go, how much
would you win?
Add it to if you flip a tail
on the third go, how much
would you win?
And we sum all of these.
But because the game hasn't got
a fixed end point, we sum
infinitely many of these.
And in fact, the expected
value of each play
of the game is 1/2.
So we're adding 1/2 to
1/2 to 1/2 to 1/2
infinitely many times.
That's why the expected value of
what you will take home is
infinitely big.
BRADY HARAN: But we wouldn't
bet our house, would we?
We wouldn't bet everything.
MARK JAGO: I wouldn't.
And I don't think you would.
And--
BRADY HARAN: What
does that say?
MARK JAGO: I think it says
something interesting
perhaps about us.
Perhaps it says that we're
more risk averse than the
mathematical theory would
have us believe.
Perhaps it says that the
value of money changes
the more you accrue.
Perhaps it says something else
that we haven't quite worked
yet, that we should figure in
to what makes us rational
reasoners that we haven't yet
taken account of in the maths.
BRADY HARAN: You're sort of
saying that as if humans are
wrong to not bet everything
on it.
But surely if humans did that,
casinos would set that game up
and own all our houses by now.
MARK JAGO: Well, good point.
To make the maths come out, the
casino has to guarantee,
so you have to know in advance
that they will bet as
much as they need.
So there would have to be a
casino with an infinite amount
of money, potentially, to
put into this game.
So one way out of it is to say,
look, there's no casino
with that amount of money.
And if we say after x amount of
money has been put in the
pot, that's it, that's all
the casino can do.
Then the numbers change, and
it turns out you would be
irrational to put lots
of money into it.
We have this mathematical
theory of
rational decision making.
Most mathematical theories don't
crumble when you put
infinity in.
They work just fine.
So why is it that theories about
us, how we should or
shouldn't behave, go really
weird when you
put infinity in?
So suppose we take all the
natural numbers together.
None of those are
infinitely big.
Each one is a finite number.
But there's infinitely
many of them.
So if we were asked to count
them, we'd say there's an
infinite connection.